that was the unrealistic part we're not
going to kick anything now and
see how magically a 20-foot hole in the
wall was created
that's not going to happen at all hey gq
i'm greg shepard
a firefighter and this is the breakdown
[Music]
first up ladder 49.
[Music]
so this movie's called ladder 49 not
engine 49 so there's
a difference right so in the engine
primarily our job is to respond to
medical emergencies
and in the realm of a fire put the fire
out that's why we have all the holes in
the back
the ladder or better known as a truck
their job is to find the fire and locate
any other civilians or
people that might be in danger there's a
stain in the fire department the engine
goes to the burn center
and the truck goes to metal day there's
never any glorifying stuff in
in movies about the engine afraid of
heights are you jack
all right let's gear up pulsar what
they're going to attempt to do
is perform a roof or rescue the victim
is actually out of the area of the reach
of the ladder which is about 100 feet so
now we're going to use our rope which is
150 feet from an aerial standpoint to
get the victim
i got this try not to drop him
so in this movie joaquin phoenix is
considered the probie or the rookie the
junior member on the job from day one
out of probie school you're expected to
complete any position on any task on the
five floor we believe in all our members
to do the job
my first fire i had control so my job
was to
get water which is the most important
job on the fire ground
bad things happen when the engine does
not get water check your eggs
so what you see here are members acting
very fast and efficiently and that's
exactly what you want to be as a
professional firefighter
we practice this drill or evolution
twice a week
every firefighter across the city knows
exactly what we're doing it's
one drill
there's thousands of fire departments
all across this country and they all
have their own sops or standard
operating procedures this film was shot
in baltimore
i'm not sure if there's something that
they would do but in new york city we
would tie off
with a substantial object another member
would tie and clip in
to his harness to lower the firefighter
down to get the victim
49 of command we got a man from over the
top he just let the command know
we're going to perform more roof rescue
that's going to alert everyone including
the inside team
that might be on the 5th floor they're
going to try the absolute best
despite heat and flame to get that
individual from that window
nice and easy guys no race
one of the members actually puts the
jacket over the parapet to
ease the rope down we call that an
anti-chafing device usually comes with
the roof rescue
pack for some reason he used his bunker
jacket which is totally fine as well
it's very rare that we actually do this
but you got one shot and it has to be
perfect every time
we are trying to let the guys up above
hey
i'm two feet away i'm three feet stop
here and then recalibrate and talk to
the victim
and let them know that hey i'm here i'm
coming don't do anything i'm right here
just hold on tight uh yeah bob we're on
the scene in chopper 7.
even in a great big city like this
chances of a helicopter being there
pretty low people below filming on
citizen without a doubt
that's definitely going to happen too
wait
wait throughout the set just wait till
i'm set i love how he said hold on
stay there instead of saying things like
don't jump when i hear words like jump
unfortunately they might just do exactly
that
oh there they go put your head against
me
it's extremely important for the actual
rescuer to stay calm
you don't want to deviate from what
you've been taught and trained we're
gonna be okay you just stay calm okay
in a situation like this where the
victim is undeniably
losing control you definitely want to
ensure them that you're here
you're going to protect them you got
them don't worry about it that's very
important to
give them mental confidence that
everything's going to be okay
realistically we're not going to swing
back and forth
kicking off of the window ledge we're
not tarzan what you're actually going to
do is
stand as close as possible to the window
and have the inside team
take the windows and pull you in
ideally the inside team would get there
before you were lowered down but
nothing's perfect you know they might
have been overcoming heat and fire
that's why we have tools for
every type of situation this movie
ladder 49 they did an amazing job in
keeping it real
and showcasing everyday evolutions that
we may go through in the city the only
thing that was
troubling was the tarzan like swinging
into the middle of the street
no one's gonna do that next up the king
of staten island
you see that that's a nice straight line
yeah you guys uh
gotta do a lot of work huh of course
here everything that we do
for the firehouse is for us we're
prideful and
where we come from and where we work we
want to be the best we want to look the
best
the tasks in the firehouse are usually
divided in between the company
the engine or the truck one month the
engine may have upstairs so we're in
charge of all the beds all the sheets
cleaning up the officers rooms
and whatnot this is all called committee
work and we do this every day
seven days a week i don't even know why
you got to clean the truck
when you're trying to show up all sexy
to a fire community work
is a great way to build bonding moments
with the other members
some examples of committee work could be
changing the sheets
taping up tools cleaning tools and
taking care of the cat's litter box
[Music]
no no dalmatian contrary to popular
belief most fire houses don't have
dalmatians
we used to back in the 1800s we didn't
have fire trucks we had horses
taking us to the fires and dalmatians
are actually
amazing pets to have around horses
because it calms them down
one of the best parts about the fire
department is it's teamwork based
everything is communal even down to
us getting in the meal so we'll go out
to the supermarket together and we'll
come back and we'll prepare it and make
it together
you got to wash it in hot because of the
bed bugs what's bedbugs
bed bugs are definitely something that
uh you have to worry about
working in a large city we respond to
maybe
10 to 20 different emergencies a day
depending on what part of the city
you're in
not every civilian is living the same
way
as you may so being exposed to different
illnesses or insects is a very realistic
thing
they're a tiny insect they get into your
home
porsche so for some reason in every
firehouse there's just
one senior guy that knows everything
about
everything you never question them they
can help with your taxes
help you with your pension provide a
good divorce attorney whatever you want
we spend an enormous amount of time with
each other every day
a day tour is nine hours and a night so
is 15
but most times guys come in and work 24.
[Music]
we you know have fun with each other
sometimes sometimes there's
lessons involved with this hazing and
things that nature
is not something that we do you don't
want to make someone feel uncomfortable
or
more important you don't want to harm
anyone were you on the job when stan was
killed
what's the first thing you thought of
when you're hurt like
i wonder if he had kids being a
firefighter you know unfortunately can
affect your family life as well
you're not at home as much as someone in
a traditional nine to five
and also it's a risk factor you know
it's a very dangerous job at first
i think my family was pretty worried it
was a little stressful for them more for
them than for me you know this is
something that
i always wanted to do since i was five
that's all i ever truly want to do in my
life
is to be a firefighter so let's skip
ahead to later on in the movie
listen up we're getting multiple calls
on this box go into a fire suit up
we don't allow civilians to ride with us
in the fire trucks
especially going to emergencies it's a
safety protocol for us
sometimes we get into accidents and we
want to want anything to happen to
someone that's off duty or not a member
of the department
so that tan cloth that he's put around
his head and neck is actually called a
hood that's gonna protect
your neck and your face and your
forehead area parts that may be exposed
from the face piece and the helmet
transmit a second alarm
box 118. fire on the first and second
floor of a five-story multiple dwelling
box 118 means the address you're going
to pretty much
what's going through my head when i'm
going to a fire i want to just make sure
i have all my tools and i'm going
exactly where i need to go we're looking
at
the mbt screen it's letting us know
where it is what floor possibly any
additional
information that we may need to know
about that building i'm getting pumped
up
just mentally preparing myself for a
good fight
what you see here is a indication of one
of our
larger fires that we may face in the
city every fire scene is different
some are more hairier than others just
depends on the combustible material
that someone may have in their residence
apartment you saw the hose
being flaked out by itself as the engine
proceeded to the fire building
that is something we would do it
actually makes it easier for us to
stretch line
uh saves energy for the members
49 here comes your water hit it go ahead
so what you see here is every member has
a specific task
chauffeur hooking up to discharge
allowing the nozzleman
and the vacuum man to have water another
member climbing a portable ladder to get
inside the
fire department that's our outside event
man every position
on the fire floor is critical and
everyone needs to do their job
so here in this movie they actually did
a really good job showing how
no matter what's going on you got to get
to where you got to get and do your job
steve buscemi he's the chauffeur it's an
extremely
important job you have to get us to the
box and get there safe
he also his job is to get us water
without water
nothing good happens at a fire scene
what steve is doing is adjusting the
pressure to a specific line
at fire we can have two to three
different hand lines
off of one engine so it's very important
that you know what pressure how much to
give that specific
hand line that's why it's all color
coordinated at the pump panel it looks
like he did it before yeah
i believe steve was a firefighter as
well prior to him
becoming very famous in acting
take the aerial invent the third floor
window probably telling the ov
climb the fire truck or ladder and get
to the window
make it essentially a door you want to
make that
easy as possible to get out if you need
to retreat
[Music]
that's not something that we would do
we're not going to just dive in head
first
what they were missing was actually we
want to sound the floor make sure
it's substantial enough for our weight
then he'll go in
with his leg not just diving it with his
head engine members
and ladder members all wear the same
gear the difference is
the tools so the roof man is going to
have a saw and a high linking hook
as opposed to someone in the engine our
main job is the hose line
so irons man's gonna have a halogen and
an
axe or a mall the cam is gonna have a
water can
and a hook so the weight variances on
the position
on average the bunker gear is about 75
pounds and
you know working in a very vertical city
like new york it can be very difficult
at times
terminology in this film was pretty
accurate they used things like a
1045 which means civilian that was
in or around the idlh which means
inherently dangerous to life and health
you see here the how the portable ladder
is at the window with the fire
in real life you might have put it to
the window that
is just smoky you're not going to want
to go into part of the apartment with
completely engulfed in flames
when you can easily move it over two
feet and go into the one where it's just
smoky
so the bunker gear in this film does
look pretty accurate they probably used
models that were maybe two or three
years older than what we
currently have but it was pretty spot-on
i seen guys with that gear on
the course so what you saw there was the
firefighter giving a civilian
oxygen through his face piece to
preserve life that's something
we would do next up i now pronounce you
chuck and larry
we pride ourselves on getting in very
efficiently and fast from the time you
get the
alarm from the house watch person
letting us know what it is until we
actually own a rig
i would say within about maybe 45
seconds
and we're out the door so most times
we're around the firehouse we are just
in our uniform it could be
shorts or long pants and an apartment
issue polo
or button shirt so when the run comes in
we just run into our
bunker pants which has our boots already
assembled with them put on our coat
and our hood gloves and helmet and then
our scba's already on the rig
we still do have polls in every
firehouse it's just a faster way
for us to get down if we get a call
emergency
the calendar is a very real thing we do
have calendar for firefighters in the
city
i'm not i'm not part of that i might be
part of the dad bot edition or something
like that
but um no we host a lot of fundraisers
whether it's for our members or someone
in the community we always love helping
people you know
as firefighters that's what we pride
ourselves on
there's a pause right here we don't ride
on the outside of the apparatuses
anymore that was from the 70s
members have gotten injured by holding
on to the outside
of a fire truck
we get very minimal information about
what we're going to
maybe the building type structure how
many floors where the caller is calling
from that's not always indicative of
where the fire is
and then when we get there we get a
better sense of what's going on you
could probably see the smoke coming from
a certain floor or window and that helps
you adapt to what you're going into
that is something very real you know
you're going to get civilians running to
you with all kinds of information
you always want to be in a good head
space you want to know what the job is
what you're doing where you're going
and what you need when you get there
there's going to be all types of
distractions
cars parked on the hydrant people
yelling saying my baby's up there my
friend members up there it's a lot going
on yeah other companies coming in from
all different directions
it's very imperative that you just stay
focused and worry about the task at hand
all of the bunker gear has been fitted
for our name to be at the bottom it's
help identify you and which company
you're from
we are very strong individuals but no
one's kicking in the door if you kick
the door in that's reinforced or still
you're going to break a toe maybe
fracture your femur so we always want to
use our tools and force the door that
way
it's usually like maybe a section of
fire not
stuff over here stuff over here stuffing
to the corner it's a little hollywood
fluff
just two people searching it's not too
realistic
you should have the orange man the cam
man and the officer
which their job as an inside team is
exactly that to go inside
everything's not cookie cutter we have
certain rules and procedures and we know
what things are supposed to look like
but sometimes we have to deviate maybe
there's more than one 10 45
so now you have to veer off and get the
other civilian by yourself that happens
you know
we put the value of life above
everything let me hear that voice
all right if you have contact with the
victim that you can't see yes you're
going to constantly communicate with
them
they're in the fire they're trapped and
they hear you coming to get them
your voice is soothing to them you want
to keep talking to them keep them keep
them active keep them engaged
and it also helps you locate them
because now you can hear where they are
let's hear that voice
i would have my my face piece on
definitely looking around standing up
that's not something we would do and the
real fire will be pitch black
at this point give me a lot of smoke and
you won't be able to see a damn thing
so i would get low that's also
beneficial as well because
now if you're low you can have better
balance god forbid there's a hole in
front of you or what not
you can kind of predict that better with
crawling and having a hand out or
foot out
when they were making their way through
the hallway you saw a lot of flame on
top of the ceiling
you might see something like that in the
actual fire all right let's find a new
way
[Music]
the original path to that fire apartment
or door
was blocked off by high heat so what it
did was made a shortcut
through the wall
but they kicked it down that was the
unrealistic part we're not gonna kick
anything now and see how magically a
20-foot
hole in the wall was creative that's not
going to happen at all people of cars
it's adrenaline you know
hey buddy we're going to help you out
here come on a person this size we can't
just
drag them out or put them on our
shoulders like how you would see them in
movies
will be a good way as opposed to what
they're doing is actually
putting a girth hitch around a person's
chest and dragging them out
with your nylon weapon
there's definitely no no running up and
forcing momentum
to push people out that's very
unrealistic so overall
chuck and larry they did less than
realistic
in this the protocols procedures and
things of that nature
aren't really true to what we do but i
like the fact that they actually use
a real firehouse that firehouse is in
brooklyn and
it still kind of looks the same to this
day next up
backdraft wait wait wait wait wait
make sure you're checking first oh yeah
we weren't checking for heat at a door
before
forcing it and you want to check the
doorknob maybe it's open
maybe you don't have to force it here we
go now get that mask back up
right that's not realistic our officers
are trained to be professional as well
and they lead by example they're going
to have their face piece on as well not
just tell you to put yours on
also the officer had his coat wide open
the ironsman it was a mask up he wasn't
ready to go if
thick black smoke came billowing out
that door he might be fumbling around to
get his face piece on
and find his tools you know anything can
happen when you're not prepared
that is a pre-indicator of a bad draft
in the very near future you're going to
have
thick black velvety smoke pulsate
in and out very rapidly what they had
here was more of a light
steamy look but they got the gist of
what it would look like as far as speed
goes
[Music]
a backdraft is pretty much an explosion
of the byproducts of fire
superheated gases explode and ignite
everything
in that room what causes a bad drive is
now a sudden rush
of oxygen into that area or idlh
to be honest i never been in a backdrop
thank god that i haven't
but to the science it wasn't that
accurate because
everything in that room would be on fire
as the superheated gases
are exploding
that was a little hollywoodish whereas
more of like a fireball or
dragon breath coming at that firefighter
it's not gonna just
be pinpointed to one person or one
object in a fire room it's gonna spread
out
from a place of high pressure to low
pressure your skin starts to burn
at about 150 degrees your lungs can sear
at anywhere from 300 degrees on upward
in the back drive it's probably about
maybe 2 000
degrees so unfortunately with his face
piece compromised and
his lungs definitely for sure seared his
chances of surviving are very low
[Music]
so you got the member pretty much fully
engulfed in flame
and the nozzleman brings the line and
opens it up on him in situations like
that you have things out of the box
that's not something that we
traditionally would do
but he may have helped the situation by
outing the fire that's on him but you
gotta be careful though cause
with water and a men's heat you could
actually gave this member steam burns
all over his body as you're dousing him
with water it wasn't
too far fetched that he was able to
respond that quickly because we're
usually right there in the fire room
with the truck
i think most firefighters have seen this
film whether like to admit it or not
i wouldn't necessarily say they all
think that it's realistic but for the
simple fact that it was like one of the
first
big budget hollywood films that
portrayed our profession
that's what made it pretty popular
within our community next up
the towering inferno pull out the floor
plans on 82. we've got problems
yeah are your comm lines all set up and
tested throwing jacks on every floor i'm
going to plug into your pa system
it's very realistic that a chief on
scene is going to gather additional
resources that can help
execute to put this fire out by using
the resources that he has available
i like the fact that despite there being
a collapse and
members injured the nozzle person stood
his ground
and kept attacking the fire there's
gonna be other people right there
to help those members that were in need
or ceiling collapsed on them but
it's very important to continue to
aggressively knock that fire out
fire's moving toward the main shaft use
the scenic elevator
all right porsche never ever want to
take an elevator during a fire emergency
people have died by doing this if you
can
walk down the stairs as firefighters
yeah there are instances where we might
take the elevator
and that's anything above the eighth
floor or higher
eight seven six five four three two one
we're gonna just walk up the stairs
we'll never get off at the fire floor
we're gonna take it two floors below
and walk the rest up please we'll use
the scenic elevators over there
this is why we have fire codes where we
have capacity limit for many occupants
that can be in one place at one time you
know it reduces the risk of hysteria and
people panicking and doing things like
overcrowding an elevator during fire
since this movie's been made we've had a
lot of technical advances
for firefighting in tall commercial
buildings like this we would have
automatic doors
that closed as soon as sensors went off
that there might be a fire or smoke
condition
also automatic sprinklers save lives it
gives us water right there where that
incident is
and a lot of times fire is put out
before we even get there in those
situations
and the standpipe we're able to get
water from every floor
and we're able to access that from
multiple locations
[Music]
what you see there is a firefighter
pulling ceiling down we do that
primarily to check for extension
to see where the fire has traveled to
generally we don't do that while we're
operating the hose line that can
cause the ceiling to collapse on the
members below that are operating to put
the fire out
i'm assuming that ringing you heard was
an indication
that that member had a quarter or less
of oxygen left to breathe
in his cylinder get another tape
when we hear that we start to make our
way out what i didn't like was
he uh gave up the nozzle we won't do
that ever
ever especially not to achieve not only
is it written that you have a position
and you should fulfill it you know we
have too much pride
to give up the nozzle if we have to give
it up we'll give it up to somebody
behind us in our own company
to our inferno it seems semi-realistic i
like how the vibe alert went off and it
alerted the member that he was low
on breathing air some things weren't as
accurate like
pulling ceilings while here advancing
and obviously
the chief taking the line that that's
not gonna happen
next up mr deets
jesus fire fire we should help
we should let's get going firefighters
love
to do what they do even your off-duty
you may go
to a scene that you may live by or just
in the area
long fellow deeds mandrake falls
volunteer fire chief i'll be up there in
a gif buddy
but it's pretty unrealistic that someone
that's
an off-duty volunteer firefighter would
impede the fire operation
that's being conducted by another
department all together he's not gonna
have a guy come off the street and be
like hey
i'm coming in to help you guys out
that's not really gonna happen
it's an honor to work for new york's
bravest guys volunteer five fives are
great you know
they do what they do they love their
community we have a lot of volunteer
firefighters
in our department as well everyone i've
come across they've been very
knowledgeable and just good people in
[Music]
if you general to a fire scene and
someone hanging out the window you can
probably
reach them through the aerial ladder or
the inside team
the truck can pull her in from the
window and if that doesn't work we could
also lower a member from the roof
they'll grab her from the window and
we'll lower them down to the floor below
or two floors below
oh lord here calm down
this part of the clip was a little
frustrating to watch the fact that there
was literally one box of cereal on fire
that's not realistic
you know maybe a whole section or
portion of the apartment would be on
fire
not just one item i'm not leaving
without my kids
how many do you got seven holy sh
how they were just talking so clear and
carefree it's not gonna happen it's
gonna be a lot of smoke
someone without the gear that we have
more than likely to be coughing and
choking from the thick smoke that's in
their apartment
the cats the cats are you know very
important
they are life we love animals we do
whatever it takes to save
human and pet life you know they might
run away from you or whatnot but
i'm gonna try my best to grab them and
hold on to them and take them out of the
uh
smoky condition and get some oxygen to
that animal or pet
[Music]
[Applause]
that circular device that you might see
in circuses
or whatnot that's not something that we
actually use it's called a
broader life net it was introduced to
fire departments
in the 1800s but was taken out of
service in our department in the 70s we
took it out of service because people
have gotten severely hurt from missing
the net or bouncing off of it or
falling through it so we no longer use
that at all whatsoever
are you okay yes i
am thanks to you
[Applause]
mr deeds was a bit far-fetched just
because it was a
off-duty volunteer guy going in and
threw like
40 cats out the window and the one box
of cereal that was on fire and that got
to me
next up rescue me y'all dudes hey
nice and cool [ __ ] yeah it's great we
all go to fires in the middle of summer
you'll be the top floor
you come back you're drained you beat
but i've never seen anyone drink water
from the engine
it's nice it's cool
fresh can you yeah sure you just hook up
the bent tip nozzle to the discharge and
you know you could
pull some water out of that but no one's
going to do that you're supposed to fill
the cooler with water
every fire truck in the city
has a five-gallon gatorade cooler and we
fill it with ice at the change of
every tour but also we have a rack unit
they have
water and gatorade for us as well so
there's no need to drink
the rusty water coming from the engine
it's just the same as drinking water and
tiger water
no it's not the same ass every fire
engine
in the city has 500 gallons of water
already in their rig or apparatus but it
gets replenished with the
hydrogen water that's coming from the
main we don't mix the the water with
fire retardant other than uh we're doing
a foam operation
we'll mix the water with foam we have a
chemical fire
what not we'll use that operation but
normally no there's no additives into
the water
what you're seeing here is more than
likely after the fire it's put under
control
and everyone's just recouping we should
do that by the fire truck after the
fire's put
no out how good the ice cream truck
looks we're a professional fire
department and you know we want to
uphold those standards
what the hell is this it ain't a sunday
picnic in the park
no one's gonna do that no one's gonna
rush a ice cream truck it's not gonna
happen and more than likely we probably
wouldn't have any money on us anyway we
don't carry cash with us
on the way to emergencies
you got any strawberry shortcake things
in there as for this clip i think rescue
me did a good job of portraying what
it's like to
be an actual firefighter it looks
realistic the gear
in the manner in which you guys speak to
each other it seems pretty accurate
next up chicago fire
[Music]
there's no standard fire truck per se
every city
every department has their fire trucks
specifically made
for that environment or terrain even in
a larger department we may have
different types of
apparatus for different types of
emergencies hey we got a driver painted
side so what we have here is a truck
full of propane tanks
and a car that's crashed into it i also
saw a firefighter in the beginning
trying to knock it down with a foam can
maybe the engine wasn't there
you know the guys with the holes in the
water it's okay it cools
some others and suppresses whatever
you're trying to knock down
get those flames out coffin i was a
little worried about the distance
in which he was that's why stretching
the hand line would have been bad in
that situation
hemline is another name for the holes
that we stretch to
fire emergencies all right 81 let's get
the driver out
gutters jaws i ain't worried about the
guy in the car
that's that could be trapped or pinned
if you listen they were talking about
bringing out the jaws of
what we life the hearse tool when you're
operating that you need
a hand line there as well as far as
hollywood goes and
so far so good propane tanks in the back
of the truck
they're right in the flames the propane
tanks those explode
you're worried about fire and
projectiles you want that guy away from
exploding propane tanks as fast as
possible
but pulling the truck that they're in
and you don't know if they have any
severe neck or head trauma
might not be the way to go you can
actually cause more damage that way
having a hose line there will actually
shield you
from advancing towards that danger and
also
they're pulling out the hearse tool you
want to have that just in case it
generates sparks that can actually cause
a fire or explosion as well
the best way to combat that situation
would be to get water on the
tanks cool it down and that's going to
limit the risk of it
actually exploding i would at least try
that before i would
jerk a two-toned vehicle with someone in
there with head or neck trauma
ems without a doubt will be there but
until we transport that patient to them
this is our scene we're gonna go in and
command the scene
and make sure things are done adequately
before we transfer him off to ems
all right boys let's put this fire up
overall i think chicago fire had a good
understanding of what we made
do but they added a little too much
hollywood to that
clip thanks for watching these clips
with me it was great
gq i love you see you next time